escribe de por cuatro de la cuarta
elevado a la un medio como una expresión
radical el punto clave aquí es tomar en
cuenta que por definición si elevó a
algo al un medio esto es igual a la raíz
cuadrada principal de ese algo vamos a
aplicar eso aquí donde tenemos cuatro dé
a la cuarta elevado a la un medio y lo
voy a hacer con dos colores aquí tenemos
entonces de que multiplica a cuatro de a
la cuarta elevada a lo medio lo cual por
definición en la raíz cuadrada principal
de cuatro de a la cuarta ya te mostraré
en otros vídeos el por qué es posible
aplicar esta propiedad de los exponentes
y esto lo podemos simplificar como ya
sabemos que aquí estamos buscando la
raíz principal de esto de aquí déjame
escribirlo de la siguiente manera esto
es igual a de por la raíz principal de 4
por la raíz principal de de a la cuarta
la raíz principal de de a la cuarta la
raíz principal de cuatro es 2
por supuesto tenemos el d por delante de
x 2 por la raíz principal de díaz la
cuarta la raíz principal desde a la
cuarta es d cuadrada de cuadrada y no
tengo que preocuparme por el valor
absoluto pues aunque desea negativo al
elevarla al cuadrado siempre va a ser
positiva si dentro del radical
tuviéramos de cuadrada entonces sí
tendríamos que pensar en incluir el
valor absoluto aquí y esto a la vez
podemos simplificarlo como tenemos de
por dos por de cuadrada esto va a ser
igual tenemos de cuadrada y de la misma
base podemos sumar los exponentes para
obtener d a la tercera potencia si es
que esto es igual a 2 por d kubik ahora
otra manera de hacer esto es un uso
directo de las propias de los exponentes
así es que esto es igual a d por lo que
está dentro del paréntesis y aquí hay
que tomar en cuenta que si tienes el
producto de algo y luego elevado a un
exponente es lo mismo a elevar al
exponente cada uno de los términos
individualmente y luego realizar el
producto por lo que esta parte de aquí
la puedo describir como 4 elevada a la
potencia un medio
de la cuarta elevada a la potencia un
medio ahora 4 elevado a los medio es
literalmente la raíz principal de 4 que
es 2 y de a la cuarta elevada a la un
medio aquí vamos a aplicar la siguiente
propiedad de los exponentes si tenemos
algo elevado al ave y esto a la vez
elevado a la c esto lo mismo a ese algo
elevado al producto de los exponentes
ave por c y esto te lo probaré alguna
vez en otro vídeo aplicando esa
propiedad aquí tenemos de a la cuarta
elevada de un medio es de a la cuatro
por un medio cuatro por un medio el
todos así es que estoy aquí es de al
cuadrado y que tenemos lo mismo de por
dos por de cuadrada lo cual es igual a
dos de kubica